right joining us now president Trump's
attorney former New York City Mayor Rudy
Giuliani mr. mayor good to see you thank
you for being on that was it that was an
absolutely terrific monologue I have to
say I coming through that's those are
those are high words of pray sir and
we've been friends a long time we have
used to call into my late-night radio
show that's not far about when you were
mayor you know a full complete
vindication especially the obstructions
out I mean the the attorney general said
it's over quoted Muller also said he'd
released the report
this wasn't a comprehensive summary of
the report but it's interesting while no
mo didn't make a decision on the
obstruction side of things he just laid
it out and handed it to the Justice
Department which then immediately
clearly the Attorney General and rod
Rosenstein said no well I mean first
first of all one of the things the
Democrats are doing today and the day
before on collusion let's be clear
mowett did reach a conclusion that there
was no collusion of any kind he went so
far as to say he used all the words you
could possibly use conspiracy
coordination not just with the president
but with the entire staff so that's
about and that comes from moer
on obstruction he said I don't find any
I don't find any basis to charge a crime
but I can't exonerate and the difficult
issues of Laurin fact I imagine he had
he had like a dispute being his staff
but none of it amounts to a finding of a
crime and prosecutors are not supposed
to exonerate generally so he apparently
three weeks ago he gave it to the
Attorney General
Rosen Stein and the office of legal
counsel they spent three weeks looking
at it and came to the conclusion I've
told you from the very beginning this
whole obstruction theory is a creation
of Andrew Weissman who created crimes
before and been been reversed by the
Supreme Court of the United States for
finding crimes out of the thin air and
in that case against businessmen he
didn't like in this case against
Trump who he despises I mean this is a
Hillary Clinton part of him this is a
guy who worked with Peter struck who we
know hates Trump
I mean MoMA had on his staff eight or
nine Trump haters which is unprecedented
in the prosecution staff so if they
didn't find a basis to charge him with
anything they exonerated him they did
everything they could including putting
a man in solitary confinement for eight
or nine months to break him and they
couldn't break him so it was about as
big of exoneration as I've ever seen and
I've been in the prosecution business
for I don't know since 1970s and to try
to reverse it is I mean I think they
look they look foolish and they look
pathetic and I am confident that the
rule said this from the very beginning I
haven't read the report I haven't seen
it they can put out every part of it it
is not going to show either one
otherwise you couldn't come to the
conclusions you came to and second if
they have a few nasty facts in there I'm
ready to slam it down their throat
because we have an 87 page report which
we will use and there's some things that
the special counsel did that I don't
think they're going to want people to
hear they acted in ways that outraged me
as a person who cares about justice
you know let's start with the team that
was appointed how do you justify only
democratic donors being appointed by
Muller how do you justify hiring Hillary
Clinton's attorney I you know you
mentioned Andrew Weissman we have gone
over this record a lot as a result he
once he was held responsible for
withholding sculp Ettore evidence tens
of thousands of Enron accounting people
lost their jobs over turn nine Oh in the
Supreme Court that doesn't happen a lot
and then put four Merrill executives in
jail for a year that was overturned by
the Fifth Circuit how does somebody like
that get chosen in this that I have a
big problem mr. mayor well you should
have a big problem Sean it's outrageous
and it never should happen again I mean
I I had great respect for Bob Mahler
when he was first appointed although you
know people what I said well yeah this
is a fair guy then when he picked the
staff that he picked I thought he kind
of lost his mind
I mean you don't pick a council to the
Clinton Foundation to investigate Donald
Trump any more than if I were
investigating Hillary I pick council to
the Trump foundation if I did the New
York Times The Washington Post and all
those characters would go nuts so that
was the first giveaway Weisman is
probably the most notorious federal
prosecutor you could find everything
done wrong in this investigation he's
done wrong before he charged non crimes
that was a Supreme Court reversed him
for he charged people with things that
are not crimes well he's done that in
this case obstruction that's his crazy
theory that not is not a legitimate
theory and the prosecution of Cohen for
campaign fraud that's ridiculous theory
he made it up let me last quick question
and by the way I'm nobody that should be
questioning I know your legal background
you were in the Southern District of New
York as prestigious you you've
prosecuted some of the toughest mob guys
in the country
why waive executive privilege why
wouldn't why would I don't think that
should happen maybe I have no idea what
I'm talking about
well I think the question is and if
there's any kind of privilege asserted
the it's gonna be oh what's there what's
there what's there I can't I can't give
you an opinion on executive privilege
I'm not the White House Counsel and I'm
not bar I don't see all of that I can
only give you the opinion in this
private lawyer I don't care what they
put out he didn't collude he didn't
obstruct God do we have to say it again
you're right and I can prove it so give
me what you got and I will knock it out
of the ballpark that's a truth how about
that the truth I won't I do
its 87 pages you're a reporter I want to
see it yeah well you'll see it's not one
day and I hope I don't have to use it
but if we have to use it he didn't
collude he didn't obstruct grow up guys
it's like getting used to the fact he
got elected go see a psychiatrist calm
down I'm gonna just to the real world
well I want to see that I want to see
the FISA applications I want to see
three million perjury prosecution
guaranteed they probably set it off told
me on Wednesday no guess the mayor thank
you for being with us on this busy
breaking news night